smell out hamdulillah
welcome to the DS Show I'm Eddie your
host and we got on the DS show today and
Islamic Exorcist that's right you have
those who are out there chasing the the
unseen world the paranormal and we had
someone contact us and this person who
actually does this for a living
he was asking us what is the Islamic
stance you know there's a lot of haunted
houses out there you know the unseen
world and ghosts and spirits and spooks
so what do you Muslims have to say so we
bought it brought on the D show someone
who does this who has a lot of
experience in this to answer give the
Islamic perspective on the unseen world
of the spirits the jinn so we write back
with an actual Islamic Exorcist or one
who does the exorcism rocky here on the
Dean show don't go anywhere
this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
days of the theme this is the theme you
know this is the theme parks around
Haroon half as hard on how you doing
brother hamdulillah suppose it'll be
ready thank you for being a deed show
with us vertical ethic mellow bless you
all the way from Detroit yes so you
studied in Morocco yes six years was it
yeah six years tell us a little about
yourself you know somehow Allah my
parents see me overseas when I was nine
years old and I stayed in Morocco for
about six years where I studied you know
memorize the Quran the Arabic language
decided Islamic jurisprudence and things
like that so hamdulillah how did you get
into the Islamic where you got Islamic
exorcism Islamic exorcism somehow Allah
how did you get into that well it's an
interesting story you know so hon Allah
while you're learning it overseas it's a
very small and simple subject but most
of the knowledge that you get if not all
of the knowledge that you get which
which was in my case was book knowledge
so you don't really have much hands-on
experience if you go to your local Imam
who had any kind of experience with it
or who has studied anything about it
most likely they have they'll probably
refer you to an expert who has had
experience who has been taught by
another export and so on and so forth so
when I came back here to the US
initially there was this one brother may
Allah surrounds on our Blessed women
award and was doing much better now his
name was Abdul Aziz and he he had some
serious problems and he comes into the
mission I really didn't understand what
was wrong with him and I asked him you
know what are you okay I saw him new in
the mission so you know usually when you
see somebody new you want to give him
some arms and things like that I say why
are you here
you know what brings you to the Med ship
them it's like oh I'm here to meet
chicken Jim Cheryl Jim so yeah I have a
jinn problem I have a problem with spear
it's mom so I was kind of interested in
what what was going to happen so I met
with that brother Mel was haunted by
some award him and that was my first
exposure to a real session that was
around 2003 2004 and then the brother
Mel was found abandoned warden he taught
me a lot of the ins and outs of you know
doing it okay this is all with the Quran
all with the Quran all of the Quran of
course you would use you know
supplications from the Sunnah of the
Prophet sallallaahu something different
do i yes you would seek refuge in Allah
subhanAllah you know you would say stuff
like a lady Chautala regime I would be
like Eileen what we watch here can I
translation cutting so out of elaborate
on regime means I seek refuge in Allah
in God from the cursed devil
yes or you would say I would be like
loudly and there are many more like I
seek refuge in Allah the Magnificent
yeah right
what be watching Karim and with his
generous face was so funny help Adam and
his old or ancient authority min
ash-shaytaan-i'r rajeem from the cursed
devil and there are many supplications
that you can use like this that are from
the Sunnah of the Prophet Allah so this
was your first time it's your first
experience that was my first experience
yes yeah so you heard me when I went
open the show I told you what what what
stimulated us to do this topic was we
got contacted by a person who actually
he's either involved with different they
call paranormal as a paranormal
investigators yes I believe so
yeah and you actually got a chance to
talk to him was named Randy Randy yeah
so real nice guy yeah real nice guy and
we wanted to do this special episode for
all his viewers also and all his friends
and all the people who are they actually
do this for a living
well yeah they do this for a living
they're out there you know when someone
has a haunted house or was presume you
know things are just moving around they
call these guys well so they want to
know the Islamic perspective okay you
know anything about this about what what
did he tell you about the paranormal
did he talk to you a little bit about
what he does
is how his radio show where well he sent
me to a couple of links
I don't recall the links right off the
top of my head but he sent me talk about
a couple links which I haven't had the
opportunity to look at yet but some of
the things that he explained to me was
that his organization definitely seems
to be Christian based or Catholic based
in particular and one of the questions
for example was how do we view or do we
take offense for example would we allow
a Catholic priest to come in to our
homes and do a cleansing of the home or
would we take offense if we saw a
Catholic priest doing a cleansing in
performing a spiritual cleansing of the
home and I told him no you wouldn't
really take any offense for you know if
we saw someone a Catholic doing you know
a spiritual cleansing we respect all
religions and this is part of our Creed
but we wouldn't allow you know it's
prohibited for us to allow a Catholic
priest to come into our homes because
they call on other than allah subhanho
wa taala
you know they'll call on you know along
with but with using the father they'll
say they use you know the Son and the
Holy Ghost and we know those to be
things that go against our belief system
which we consider [ __ ]
which means associating partners with
allah subhanallah making people equal to
a loss of hano hano
so they lead to the question that he had
he said how did the Muslims deal with
paranormal investigators how would they
deal with someone like that so he wanted
to know Islam encourages any kind of
research as long as it's within the
guidelines of permissible permissibility
as long as it's within the guidelines of
permissibility meaning what a loss of
Hannah what Allah allows and what the
prophets of Allah does Allah through the
hadith or through the sayings or his
traditions allowed and so if a person is
interested in seeing maybe they saw like
a black shadow in the corner and they
want to investigate they buy some
equipment
to try to see if they can pick up sounds
or they get some infrared cameras to see
if they can pick up some kinds of images
and things like that and they're doing
it out of curiosity they want to do
research any kind of research in Islam
is permissible but once you get into
worshiping other than Allah Ta'ala or
doing things because a lot of the times
they'll call on these unseen beings
these gyms they'll say if you are here
can you do this and they're calling on
them you know once you start calling on
other than allah subhanaw taala or
supplicating to other than Allah Allah
when you say a lost want Allah for many
of the viewers to an end what you're
talking about the Creator the Creator
got got one and only the maker of
mankind yes sir
please continue the maker of the heavens
and earth yes so when we get into
calling on other than Allah Allah Allah
and then we this is also a form of
associating partners with God which is
clearly forbidden in Islam Islam came to
teach the oneness of allah subhanho wa
taala and so we want to make sure we
stick to those guidelines regardless of
what we do so in a nutshell
investigating is permissible but calling
on other than God is not and when we say
calling on God along s that pure
monotheism yes right mhm
yeah now if we look back and we see that
okay there is a maker that designed this
whole universe and everything in it he
also let's take it back tells us about
the common enemy to mankind yes and this
is the Shaitaan the devil yeah tell us
how they started you know it's it's an
amazing this is a beautiful story and
this story coincides with some of the
story of the Bible but it disagrees with
some of the story of the Bible before we
get into the story we have to get into
the context inshallah tada and the first
part is the creation of man the creation
of angels and the creation of jinn as
three separate beings not two separate
beings creation of mankind AHA the
creation of the Angels the angels and
the creation of jen-jen can you can you
translate Jenna spirits spirit
okay okay now unlike the common
understanding
we don't believe gin to be or spirits to
be dead people who have passed on nor do
we believe that spirits are angels that
have fallen okay
we believe that jinns were created and
they have the male of them in the female
of them meaning they have children they
have offsprings they have family members
that have cousins and cousins of cousins
right where angels are create and and
well and jinns are created from fire
smokeless fire and a lot phones are
clearly states in the Quran as for
angels they're created out of light okay
and a certain kind of light which we
can't see right and as it would as
modern science furthers in their
research we understand that there are so
many different kinds of lights that we
still have yet to discover and man is
created from out of clay out of dirt and
so insha'Allah Allah we're going to talk
about the how all of it started in sha
allah but first we have to have a clear
guideline as to who is what understand
I'm saying yes okay let's let's hold off
there we're going to take a break we
right back with more on this very
interesting topic here in the Disha
take that simple step that you asked
your maker to guide you that he'll guide
you yes III advise this a lot for people
researching put your head on the floor
in the in the in the state of
prostration like all the prophets did
and ask the creator of the universe to
show you the way to guide you to the
straight path and someone who sincerely
asked for guided suppose if there is
something buried some things were you
madman watch deed show the Dean show
welcome back to the Dean show our guests
half is her own along with study
memorizing the verbatim Word of God is
one of the living miracles that we have
yeah verbatim word of God the crime
memorized by millions you're one of
those here today I'll come to that home
did it up a lot bless me would be one of
those yeah I mean you try to memorize I
mean just if somebody would let me take
just an average book I mean let me see
what I can give we take a book here this
one is uh shake July a boob 50 of the
and I advise people to get this book
counselors brought by the problem harm
peace be upon try memorizing this book
I'm just picking a random book but get
the book it's a good book so have you
heard of people just memorizing entire
books yes but not oh you talking from
the Islamic concept but it's a concept
yes for an Islamic concept but in
today's day and age I mean you try to
remember I just want most some small
pamphlet you can't do it yeah that's a
miracle you know yeah we have people
like Mambo hottie and yeah memorized you
know they had that that gift but that's
the Islamic that's that's one of the
miracles so so you also work with Sheikh
Yusuf Estes I got his TV yes shout out
of shape so I like home sit
so I guess this guy does TV you're also
with him there let's continue on you're
talking about the story of the first man
Adam and his how he and the angels and
the spirit jinn right continue on so
this story of Adam and beliefs and the
angels and his wife ha or Eve it's an
amazing story so hard when there's so
many lessons that you can learn from it
but we're going to focus on one part one
aspect of it we're going to focus on the
relationship that Adam had with shape on
satan iblees right and the relationship
that Adam had with the angels and the
relationship that Adam had with Allah
and the relationship that Allah Allah
Allah when we had with the other three
that we just mentioned and so who was a
please who was she upon who was Satan
Satan we know in Islam - he was one of
the most devoted worshipers among the
jinn he was such a devoted worshiper
that God allowed him to sit in the
circles of the Angels I mean this is a
high honor you can imagine you know for
the Christians you know we we know that
Jesus is honest and I've had a
relationship with the Angels you know he
would receive revelation from the Angels
muslims we believe and muslims we
believe the same thing and we believe
that mohammed salah salem had
relationship with the angels he received
revelation from the angels and he would
occasionally see angels the based on a
lot of the different hadith
we know that all of the prophets were
received a certain kind of revelation
from the angels it would come from the
crater that happens in earth to the hill
to the prophets to the prophets like
angel jaded Gabriel Gabriel Gabriel yes
okay and so uh beliefs or Shaitaan or
the state or saying hat was able to sit
in the circle circles of the angels
right in the gatherings of angels and
this was the high esteem that God had
for him for him because of his devotion
of worship but
was a problem the problem was his lack
of sincerity right and this is proven a
little bit later on so one day a lot of
hot water I'll that says in lee ji-yoon
feel of the Haditha right I am to put on
the earth and inheritor a ruler someone
to take over someone so to to run the
earth a human being he in this ayah it
doesn't specify a human being but this
is was like on it this verse implies
Adam at what is the first human being
okay um and so Allah says Allah says in
the jackal if I'm putting an inheritor
or rulers who want to run the earth and
the angels respond I touch I Luffy ha my
UFC doofy huh West we could be mad or I
don't know sub B ho behind Iike what
this black are you going to put in it
someone who's going to shed blood right
and cause corruption in the land so the
angels are saying are you gonna put
someone who's going to cause havoc in
earth basically yes bloodshed and this
was going on today and they're getting
this from the experience that they had
before with the gyms and this is you'll
find this in some of the tough serials
or explanations of the Quran based on
some of the hadith that the Angels
became I'm sorry that the jinns became
corrupted and you know they started
called shedding blood and the whole
earth was kind of like you know without
leader without leadership and anytime
you have something with our leadership
of course there's a lot of chaos
so when angels said this what happens
next they're saying it's to the Creator
they're saying is they're asking the
creator they're not questioning the
Creator as a difference between
questioning and asking right and so
they're asking out of curiosity is this
what so what's going to happen right so
they say
so Allah so Allah or God says in the
Adam merit animal I know what you don't
know right and so they stopped they
stopped so eventually Allah so it's on
our God created Adam first man the first
man and when God created Adam released
Shaitaan or the Satan was jealous
of this person why because he felt that
he deserved that spot he wanted to be
the one in charge of the earth and so
remember we were talking about his
devotion at one point in time right now
he's jealous and this is going to bring
out his true intentions behind his
devotion so when God honors Adam and
tells the angels to prostrate to bow
down to Adam right all of the Angels bow
down to Adam and it shows their pure
intentions this bowing down this is what
wasn't a bowing down of worship was it
it was a respect bowing down to other
people was permissible before the time
of before the time of Prophet Muhammad
also before the time mm-hmm when the
Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu Selim came
please peace and blessings be upon him
when he came he prohibited it because
this was a formal way of worshipping
other than God all right
but before they used to do it out of
respect like Jacob Jacob his son his uh
Joseph and his his brothers frustrated -
Joseph and his mother and father
you know they prostrated to Joseph God
tells Adam to be prostrated - by the
Angels and by Iblees or Shaitaan or the
devil himself and here at least disobeys
a direct command from God mm-hmm and
what does he say how could I you created
me I'm better than him you created me
from fire you created him from dirt
that's the this is can we say the
original sin the the first since the
original sin well so this is the first
sin there were sins before yeah because
if you recall there were jinns before
okay one causing corruption this is the
first thing that we know of so this is
the sin the the sin of arrogance pride
and we see a lot of that happen in the
world
yes right and that's the source of just
about every form of this relief every
you have the truth in front of you and
you don't even you have the truth in
front of you and you don't even believe
it mm-hmm you know this is this wall is
white no no no no my grandparents told
me that this wall is green look at this
white yeah right and just like the same
thing God has given us signs throughout
the heavens in the earth we have he's
created for us the moon and the stars
there's nothing that benefits like the
human being from the entire earth
nothing absolutely nothing the Lions
don't benefit from the earth like people
the elephant's the benefit from the
earth like the people
nothing benefits from the earth like the
people like mankind but yet we are the
only ones who worship other than him God
has sent us all of this as a sign for us
to be able to see who he is for us to be
able to even if we can't see him his
signs are there but yet we disbelieve in
him how do we connect this now - okay so
this is what we have how how it all went
down so now this is that enemy to human
beings right is the jinn yes the the I
mean you have this beliefs the devil so
now you have you know a lot of people
who have dedicated their lives you know
and and and this is something that's
proven you know you have a lot of people
who have gone out with these equipments
and they've gone to these houses or you
know certain places and there are just
paranormal things that are going on yes
even someone who might not believe in
God Yuni sees an unidentified flying
object
no UFO they call them you know these
these are you could say the jinn because
they travel how they travel very fast
isn't that so when we when we pin when
you read the the Islamic description you
could pinpoint that these are the action
of those periods is that true yes based
on there is a difference of opinion as
to actually what it is because there are
some a hadith that may link to them as
being angels and then there are other
hadith that may link to them as being
the jinns so we leave it to what allah
subhanallah allah knows best right
as we're not sure so we go to a La Scala
but we know that there were beings
moving at the speed of light as it
stated in the both jinns and then the
jinns and this is stated clearly in the
traditions of the Prophet SAW Allah
Allah said Lamia so linking that to what
we have what we're experiencing today
she upon I believes is from the unseen
from the unseen we can't see him we
can't feel him and we can't touch him
yeah right
but he does bother us and this he has
made his life mission and God has given
him respite until the day of judgment to
mislead people to mislead people before
we go to break don't lose your place but
I want to just oh listen have you heard
this this saying that the biggest trick
that devil played on human beings is
what what to make people believe he
doesn't exist yeah yeah can we say that
yeah I guess so I guess so that's
because if you don't believe he exists
you don't know your enemy yes and then
you'll be sucked you're being tricked so
we're gonna be talking more about this
and we have some more questions that we
need you to answer here in a disha we'll
be right back she had often miss
translated as holy war the word jihad
means to struggle Islam does not preach
violence it does not preach vicious holy
war it certainly does not condone terror
and suicide bombing Islam preaches
compassion tolerance and justice find
the truth about Islam call toll-free 877
why Islam order your FREE copy of the
Quran today I'm not afraid to stand
alone if Eliza
I am Not Afraid of stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone
if Allah is by my side I am Not Afraid
to stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone if Allah is by my side
I am Not Afraid to stay
back here on the D show with our brother
in your brother harun and we're talking
about the the spirits the unseen world
and it's interesting that some people
who when the topic of the creator comes
up and talking about the purpose of life
and you know these are these are things
of the unseen and many people who don't
let's say what don't follow any religion
or don't worship the Creator or follow
you know the messengers that were sent
you know when they all came with the
same message where's the Creator not his
creation its lavash to the will of God
and you know they'll come up with many
funky ideas you know that about Martians
by aliens yeah this is crazy things to
us yeah we think about it but when we're
talking about this I mean I mean you
like I said that there are you know
people there there are paranormal things
that happen how would we define
paranormal they'll be like things are
out of the ordinary out of the ordinary
yeah normal paranormal something that is
not normal and this is this is fact yes
it's not fiction but Islam has the
answers to it what's really going on
behind the scenes that true definitely
yeah definitely and that's one of our
pillars of faith yeah we're a lost one
or God says Allah DNA monona bill vibe
right they when God is first talking
about the people who fear Him or who are
devoted to him he said they are the ones
who believe in the unseen unseen yes
yeah and this is part of our opposed a
faith Randy from the paranormal
investigators he's asking he said does
the jinn pose an issue if the paranormal
investigator
pushes or provokes the spirit and that
divides into two different categories
right the first kind of develop
provoking a spirit based on what I
understand it requires one to call on
the spirit for example if you are in
this room with me then I need you to tap
on the desk
twice right now you're calling on
something that may or may not be there
right and this is associating partners
with God we don't call on anyone other
than God right but another form is
something that we always do in the
right where we may we may seek refuge in
God from the devil or we may ask a Lost
Planet I'll make ask God to destroy the
devil we may ask we may tell them to
leave out of this house right like the
letter which is from a non authentic
hadith but it's a letter of Buju Jannah
which states in it right oh hello jewel
in the Hat oh hello jewel Manhattan my
Kevin get leave out of this place and
the province of Austin and when he would
read on a person when he would do an
exorcism on a person right one of the
narration says he was doing an exorcism
on a boy and he would blow into his
mouth and would say come out you enemy
of God I am a servant of God come out
you enemy of God I'm a servant of God
doing that's like the exorcism yes yeah
and so you can call that a form of
provoking but rather it's a form we
would consider a form of attacking but
calling on them in order for them to do
things for you and you don't even know
if they're there or not is a different
tunnel issue this is what you see a lot
of like the they call them the you know
the jay-z's and what do they have a
group for them you know they have the
special sign what does it call
loominatee the Illuminati and you'll
know I mean they have these séances and
they actually call on the spirits to
help them and they've written about this
you have this in there and you know and
believe Aleister Crowley's book you know
that many of them that's like their ship
they go by have you heard of this no
Alice and many of them you know they
actually you know as you can say they
sell their souls to the devil
mmm so they'll call on the devil's
because don't you have multiple you have
like the main devil then you have the
how does that work
the Iblees Shaitaan right it's saying he
has a few high governors right and those
high governors have people who are under
them and then there when we said that we
can seek refuge in God from the devil we
can say I will be let him in a shape on
the regime in warm ingenuity he what not
he right see provision god from the
devil and from his soldiers and from his
children but nonetheless what they're
doing
is an ancient ancient just ancient form
of witchcraft
it hasn't witchcraft 4,000 years that's
people want money they want power they
want status and they'll do anything to
get it so they call these spirits to
help them and unfortunately those things
don't help them not in this life and not
the next right and it it's it boils down
to them just believing that it's working
and really and they give they give them
some temporary victories maybe they
think they're they help them in their
transgression will they'll they'll want
something they'll say help them to
achieve a certain status they think is
good from but actually that's destroying
them there's a possibility they want to
be the biggest rock star for instance
there's a possibility that I can now
they get to that that level of Fame but
that actually destroys them and then
they worship them more yes there's a
possibility that that it can help them
lead to that but if you really look at
the at most of the magicians the most of
most of the people who deal with
witchcraft yeah let's say you go to
example Zanzibar with a lot of the
voodoo priests or you go to like the the
bushes of Africa or down in the jungles
of the Amazon and you see these people
who are heavy into this kind of stuff
you realize that the best of these
people don't even have the wealth that
they're seeking mmm they don't so just
like with anyone else our provisions was
written before we were born and it
doesn't matter what we do we're going to
get it we're going to get it whether we
call engines or whether we don't we're
going to get it we're going to get it so
why do something that God has forbidden
you to do in order to get what was
arguing for you so we're almost out of
time we almost got we got to wrap it a
few more things they asked how does the
church it's a church of a sizable Church
of Islam this is what he's saying how
does church of its not determine a jinn
if someone's possessed by a jinn there
are a few different methods of doing it
you want to first of all you want to
watch out from any kind of magician
and the signs of identifying a magician
is number one when you first talk to
them to ask you for your name and your
mother's name number two so if someone
if you go to someone for help and they
ask you for those two things make sure
I'd like run get out of the room say I'm
very sorry you don't have to be mean to
me I'm very sorry you know I'm going to
come back another time don't come back
okay so this is a tillis amore so if
someone's asking you go to someone who
said what's your mother's name bring a
picture of your dad or mother in a
picture of yourself with a person who
was that who you're intending on helping
or hurting bring nails blood bring
clothing of that particular person or so
on for so forth then you want to move on
you know to the next person who you
think might be able to help yeah
the way to identify if someone has a gin
problem at my clinic in Detroit we have
we would typically tell them to keep
their hands still something like this
here right and keep their fingers
together and we will recite the Quran
the verses that were prescribed for
exorcisms there's actual verses
everybody's got a loss in the Quran so
you recite these yes and we also recite
supplications that the Prophet used to
do that are recommended for exorcisms or
for keeping the Devils away and
initially what will happen is you start
to see separations of the fingers
because they're the jinns that are
inside the person start to suffer and
they can't stay still and it there we
don't have enough time to go through the
whole you know spiel as to what happens
but that's an initial sign some people
feel headaches some people can't listen
to it anymore they just feel like they
want to you know move it away some
people start to feel stomach pain etc
etc and some people start to feel things
moving through their body once they
start to listen to these things and so
that's one definite way to be able to
identify of course we believe in some
mental issues or some people who do have
mental issues and it has very little to
do with problems with the spirits and so
you want to be
be sure by using the proper evaluation
methods in order to evaluate whether you
have schizophrenia bipolar et cetera or
you have a gym related problem and if
you do have a general ated problem and
it's difficult to make sure you go to an
expert because it can get out of hand so
none of these talismans these
superstitions all of this stuff is out
the window all of these these these
things that you mentioned yeah you know
someone's asking you for something weird
just yeah yeah anybody gives you any
kind of talisman or it gives you
something and they tell you don't open
it if you open it you're going to die
put this in the corner of your house etc
you want to make sure you stay away from
those kind of cool yeah okay and what
else can they do now how do you stay
protected before what's the best way to
stay protected from these evil forces
that are out there
no one is absolutely exempt if anyone
was exempted would have been prophet
muhammed sallalahu them but since he was
affected by witchcraft right then we
know that no one absolutely no one is
absolutely is exempt from it but there
are things that you can do to protect
yourself as best as possible and that is
getting closer to allah praying on time
it's keep up with reading the quran or
as much as you possibly can i would tell
people two to three hours a day you want
to read from the Quran remember your
supplications of the morning and
afternoon all of these things go way
farther than you can ever then you can
ever see whenever ever imagine they're
so much better for you then most people
actually think yeah so staying connected
with the crater
yeah and doing these small making sure
you're making your prayers connecting
with the Creator through the Quran if
you can't do two three hours I mean five
minutes yeah right and the the
supplications that are there and all of
these supplications are not calling on
the creation but is calling on the
creator isn't it yes
the one and only yes thank you very much
we got to go I wish we talk some more
but a lot of time will freak them thank
you very much I'm do let does I can look
head forever
oh yeah Connie and thank you tuning in
to the Deen show every week we're here
and remember that there's one God one
creator one maker of mankind and he sent
messengers to God man
guide mankind and all of them came with
the same message versus worship the
Creator not his Christian and I remember
they all warned about the common enemy
to mankind and that's the devil does
shaitaan/the save leaves that's the one
who wants to turn people away from God's
Way from the crater's way and everything
that creator calls us do is good is
organic and everything that the devil
wants us to do is something that doesn't
bring peace and happiness in one soul
alcohol drugs and promiscuity and all
the things that just don't make you feel
good they make you feel bad so let's
start off by trying to connect with our
Creator staying away from the things
that are displeasing to the Creator and
make sure that we live a good wholesome
life that is pleasing to the one who
made mankind and whenever you're in
trouble
dial up to the one up above the one who
created you and you give us a call
steady if there is something to my
affair eight some things won't let me
watch TV show the deed show
you